J'ai été attaqué,
j'ai littéralement subi un raid
de la part d'Amixem.
Un raid pas piqué des hannetons, mon pote.
Alors, bienvenue à toutes les personnes
qui viennent de découvrir cette chaîne.
On va vous faire de la place, on va être bien.
Bon, aujourd'hui je vous propose un nouveau
format, je vous en avais parlé dans des précédentes vidéos :
on va faire une expérience ensemble.
Dans une de mes précédentes vidéos,
je vous ai parlé de l'effet "mouton-chèvre".
Quand on parle de l'effet "mouton-chèvre",
on parle de l'expérience qu'avait fait Gertrude Schmeidler...
Schmeidler ?
SCHMEIDLER !
Je sais pas comment ça se prononce...
En 1942, elle avait donc fait une expérience visant à
comprendre le processus qui peut favoriser ou inhaler
les effets psi.
Les pouvoirs parapsychologiques...
Cette expérience a beaucoup été critiquée,
elle a essayé d'être reproduite,
elle a été recritiquée...
Le 1er truc c'est l'expérience, je vous la décris en quelques mots :
il y a tout un groupe de personnes à qui on présente des cartes
avec 5 symboles différents, dans un ordre aléatoire, et elles doivent deviner dans quel ordre sont les cartes.
Ça, c'est la 1ère collecte de données; mais il y a une 2ème collecte de données, qui est qu'on
différencie les personnes qui croient aux pouvoirs psi
et les personnes qui ne croient pas aux pouvoirs psi.
Et on voit quel est le taux de réussite de chacun, ou le taux d'échec de chacun...
Et c'est là que ça devient
intéressant, puisque si ceux qui ne
croient pas du tout aux pouvoirs mentaux, aux pouvoirs psi, ont de très, très mauvais
résultats (c'est à dire en dessous, bien
en dessous de la barre du hasard),
ça veut pouvoir dire qu'en réalité ils ont capté quelque chose et que, pour que ça
aille avec leurs croyances, ils ont été
à l'inverse... Vous voyez un petit peu de quoi je parle,
même si c'est pas très clair !
Mais dans le
protocole de 1942, on ne sait pas si
l'expérimentateur lui-même connaissait,
ou pas, l'ordre des cartes.
Parce que s'il le connaissait, ça veut dire qu'il a peut-être envoyé des signaux non
verbaux - qui auraient été interprétés inconsciemment par la personne en face.
Bon après, les sceptiques critiqueront
toujours que l'argument de la
croyance n'a rien à voir dans le protocole;
mais c'est pas très grave, on s'en fiche
en fait, on veut juste tester,
voir les données et voir ce qu'il y a
derrière. On va pas chercher à faire une grande
conclusion non plus, on tente le coup.
Et je vous parle des critiques des sceptiques, mais
il y a même les critiques des
croyants aux pouvoirs psi qui disent que le
protocole, en même temps, si
l'expérimentateur de départ croit ou non
aux pouvoirs psi, peut-être que ça joue
aussi. Alors déjà, il y a un truc qui est
cool, c'est que moi je suis complètement
neutre vis-à-vis de ça, c'est-à-dire :
c'est pas que j'y crois ou j'y crois pas, c'est que je
n'ai pas tellement d'avis.
Je sais que j'ai pas de pouvoirs psi, et je sais que je
n'ai jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui m'a
démontré en avoir, en tout cas... Mais ! En plus comme on va le faire en vidéo,
je ne risque pas d'être un expérimentateur réellement,
ça va être la caméra qui va l'être.
Je vais donc mettre le protocole en place
dans quelques secondes, vous allez pouvoir
participer, je vais collecter les données
de tout le monde, et dans la prochaine vidéo
on fera une analyse précise de ces
données. J'ai besoin également de
quelqu'un de très fortement calé en maths; c'est-à-dire que j'ai fait mes propres calculs,
j'ai mes propres résultats, mais
j'aimerais qu'ils soient validés ou invalidés
par un professeur, un universitaire, ou je sais pas...
C'est pas un truc très compliqué, mais si l'un ou
l'une d'entre vous veut bien me contacter
avec un gros niveau, et de manière
à pouvoir me le prouver parce que je vais citer
cette personne-là aussi dans le calcul;
je pense que ça ne lui prendra que quelques
minutes, et ça permettra de vérifier
mon calcul à moi.
Ce serait sympathique !
On va donc changer d'environnement...
On va utiliser les cartes de Zener;
Docteur Rhine (cf Joseph Banks Rhine)...
J'ai pas ces cartes-là avec moi, mais c'est pas très grave, je vais vous faire voir
les symboles qu'on retrouve sur ces cartes-là habituellement :
il y a le cercle, la croix,
les vagues,
le carré, et l'étoile.
Voici les cinq symboles qu'on peut retrouver habituellement sur les cartes de
Rhine... Cercle, croix, vagues, carré, étoile.
J'ai également avec moi cinq bristols complètement opaques, que je vais plier en deux, et je vais
dessiner sur chacun de ces bristols l'un de ces cinq symboles.
Ensuite, je mélangerai tous les bristols de
manière à ne pas savoir moi-même
quel bristol a quel symbole, puis je
filmerai ça; je vous demanderai, vous,
de vous concentrer dessus et d'essayer de capter
quelque chose
(s'il y a quelque chose à capter), et de me
dire ensuite
dans quel ordre sont les symboles. Si
vous pensez qu'en 1 c'est le cercle,
vous mettrez "cercle", si vous pensez qu'en 2 c'est les vagues, vous mettrez "vagues", etc.
Et il y aura donc une 2ème information qu'il faudra me donner,
c'est : est-ce que vous croyez aux pouvoirs psi ? Par
exemple aux médiums, aux rêves prémonitoires,
à la télékinésie,
aux choses qui portent bonheur ou aux choses qui portent malheur...
Si vous êtes croyants dans tout ça, il
faudra me le dire
(cocher la case croyant, quoi); si, au contraire, vous êtes sûrs et certains que ça n'existe pas,
ça c'est certain pour vous, vous me le direz aussi; mais
contrairement à l'expérience de 1942,
je vais aussi collecter une partie "neutre",
pour les gens qui sont un peu plus comme
moi : c'est pas qu'ils y croient ou pas,
c'est qu'ils n'ont aucun avis dessus, ce qui est mon cas.
Et après, toutes ces données, donc, je vais les compiler et toute cette data, là, on va faire tout ce qu'il y a à faire avec
et on se fera l'analyse des résultats sur cette chaîne.
Alors c'est parti...
Voilà, je mélange les bristols, je ne sais déjà plus où j'en suis
mais je continue quand même de les mélanger...
Et je reviens, parce que j'étais parti,
je suis aussi parti boire un café (et j'ai laissé le crayon ouvert, c'est super)
pour être vraiment sûr, sûr, sûr que même inconsciemment j'avais pas repéré quelque chose
et que je me souvienne de quoi que ce soit.
Je termine de les mélanger, maintenant je vais les noter de 1 à 5.
J'ai un peu galéré à les faire tenir, c'est pour ça que j'ai posé une carte de
visite dessus, pour alourdir. Ils
sont donc numérotés de 1 à 5,
il n'y a qu'une seule fois chacun des symboles;
je vous les rappelle :
le cercle, la croix, les vagues, le
carré et l'étoile;
et donc je vous laisse vous concentrer sur les
cinq cartes pour essayer de capter quel
symbole est derrière le 1, quel symbole est derrière le 2, le 3, le 4 et le 5.
Je vous invite évidemment à
mettre pause pour ça.
C'est terminé, donc retenez ce que vous
avez ressenti, vous cliquez dans la
description, il y a un lien vers un Google Form, vous allez pouvoir me mettre les réponses.
Rappelez-vous : vous m'écrivez l'ordre
des symboles qu'il y a d'après vous de 1
à 5. Et dans la description il y a également un mail pour la
personne qui voudrait m'aider pour
valider les calculs mathématiques
que j'ai à faire. C'est un nouveau concept, dites-moi dans les commentaires également si ça vous
plaît; si c'est le cas j'en préparerai deux
ou
trois, ou peut-être quatre dans l'année -
expérience sociale, tu laisses "poce
bleu" si tu veux.
Ibra, si tu nous regarde (cf IbraTV)... Je collecterai
les données au plus tard vendredi,
puisque la prochaine vidéo, j'aimerais
bien que ce soit celle-ci, dans la
continuité tout de suite. N'hésitez pas
également à faire tourner
la vidéo; c'est pas pour la faire tourner, la faire tourner; vous pouvez même faire
juste
tourner le petit passage... C'est :
plus on aura de personnes qui
participeront, plus ce sera intéressant.
Là je suis encore en train de créer un
nouveau concept (oui je ne fais que ça, j'aime bien), ça passera
par les réseaux sociaux pour les
vidéos, donc rajoutez-moi, tout est dans
la description. Et je voulais remercier
tous ceux qui sont venus me voir jouer
à Lille, on a fait deux dates archi complètes... Vous avez également un lien dans la
description sur toutes les dates de
tournée; là pour janvier, demain je pars
à Saint Galmier, j'enchaîne avec Villars et Vienne, juste après je fais Brignoles dans le
sud, et Aix-en-Provence; et ça c'est pour janvier... Et il y a des dates jusqu'en juin.
Comme d'habitude, si ça vous a plu, vous
pouvez liker et vous abonner,
et rendez-vous... demain à 17
heures, j'allais dire, mais non c'est fini
ce temps-là...
Rendez-vous très bientôt, dans quelques
jours sur la chaîne, ciao !